I don't want to spoil it but I'm gonna
do it anyway on a future episode of the
masked singer the person who is joining
us right now for the Honda inside a
report is gonna be dressed in a
full-fledged Fred Flintstone costumes to
meet the Flintstones and he is Adam
Schefter from the worldwide leader in
sports how are you Adam you're gonna be
on the masked singer on that oh my god
are my breaking news to you have an
entire bra last night what's the matter
fingers oh gosh
all right sits on physis Fenton blanks
on that one
when Brokeback Mountain was everyone was
talking about at the Pro Bowl he had no
idea Mike Shannon was cuz he was in the
tank as a coach for weeks and months so
Adam Schefter has been deep in the news
and information tank is what you're
saying right now okay okay what am i
doing on the show so it last night it
was the premiere of the masked singer
was taped weeks and months ago and it's
about celebrities in full costume you
can't tell who they are and they're
singing a song and they're either
they're either kept on the show or voted
off and last night the blue hippopotamus
seen Bobby Brown's my prerogative was
voted off and it was revealed to be
Antonio Brown okay that's an okay that's
it how do I become a part of this it was
my joke because I thought for sure you
would know it Antonio Brown in the
middle of all this stuff his pre-taped
appearances a blue hippo singing my
prerogative is going to be revealed
Brokeback Mountain well I can't quit you
Adam Schefter
okay give me what is the latest in
Pittsburgh PA Adam I mean is that I met
Jesse James had the best description of
it that we heard of anybody show that
the Steelers have turned into the
Kardashians of the NFL that's basically
Lex right like we've seen this whole
situation go crazy it's I think it's
worse than people think
I think there's more to it than people
think and no and
when you talk to people around the leak
there's the overwhelming sense that the
Steelers are gonna wind up trading
Antonio Brown this all season that he's
played his last game for the Pittsburgh
Steelers and we'll see what that's right
now I don't think that they're planning
that today I don't think they've
discussed that today but I think that
there is a prevailing feeling that
that's the direction that this is going
to go in I think Antonia Browns gonna be
happy with that - well so what is your
first blush thought on what a market
would be like to figure out rich I mean
the Dallas Cowboys traded a first-round
pick for a wide receiver who was seven
years younger and Mario Cooper was seven
years younger twenty four years old and
20 runs 31 and 20 of runners three more
years in his contract and I'm sure by
the way when they land in a new place if
they land in a new place I want a new
contract anyway but in contract as it is
right now would be relatively friendly
competitors production you're talking
about six seven straight years of
100-plus catches unparalleled production
at the wide receiver position he's
produced like no other player in the
game over the last half half dozen years
so from that standpoint it's all there
Cooper goes for a one Brandon cooks last
offseason the Rams traded their one for
cooks in a four yep so I mean that gives
you an idea of what a guy who has
produced more than those other guys
should be worth now if there are
multiple teams maybe it was higher than
one if there's not as many teams maybe
it goes lower than a1 but I think that's
the rough baseline area that you could
expect the Pittsburgh Steelers to get
back for a player like Antonia Braun
should they follow through and go ahead
and auction them off and then there's
the the issue of obviously burning 21
million bucks for a player that they
would not have on their roster obviously
they would get some savings on their cap
after getting him off for future years
but it just doesn't strike me as the
Steelers I guess it would be such an
addition by subtraction that they would
have 21 million bucks of just dead money
on their cap going in you know what I
would say to that rich would be this
that the cap has risen so much
where it can be 190 million and yes that
handicaps you some to a certain extent
but in this league it's not about the
cap it's about cash and teams can do
anything they want with the cap they can
soften the blow in any year they want by
restructuring as many contracts as they
want by basically finagling the cat that
had to swallow any 21 million in debt
money is really not a big deal as much
as it sounds like it's a big deal
because they would free up some of the
money they would make it up through
other structures don't forget that
they're gonna have the living on bail
money that comes due so levy on bail
money off sex antonio brown money to a
certain extent and it's not difficult to
find that space if that's what they want
to do which i think that's ultimately if
you listen to mike tomlin I'm read
between the lines yesterday that seems
like they're certainly contemplating it
right now they'll have further
discussions about it and we'll see where
it all leads this offseason but I think
most people think it's gonna leave with
Antonio Brown getting out of Pittsburgh
last one for you here Adam if you your
best guess in what's going through art
Rooney's temples today knowing that
obviously as quarterbacks got some
fingerprints on this and then there's a
head coach that that has let something
like this go on I mean he is best
teacher tried to put a cap on it this
has obviously been something that didn't
just crop up in the last week to ten
days for a while and they've allowed
this to grow and become what's become
it's so unfit spurred like like if we
were talking about this being another
wide receiver we wouldn't think very
much of it we covered stories like this
for years with Terrell Owens and it
became part of the course whether it was
in Philly or Dallas or San Francisco or
whatever but when do we get drama like
this in Pittsburgh and it's been a year
of drama with levy on bail with the
offensive line saying we don't need them
we're better without them with this
Antonio Brown incident incidents I mean
that's not the Pittsburgh Steelers
that's weird
so I don't know whether that comes back
to our Trudy
well my Tomlin will Ben Roethlisberger
or levy on bail or Antonio Brown or a
combination of all of them letting you
get to that point and shame on everybody
yeah everybody deserves some blame here
but we've taken what was a proud
franchise what was a winning franchise
and made it one that everybody's mocking
and wondering what's gone wrong and
laughing about with them not making the
playoffs mm-hmm
Adam Schefter joining me here on the
riches and showing the Honda inside a
report okay so Dave gentlemen spoke to
the New York metropolitan media
yesterday and said there was a
no-holds-barred conversation with Eli
Manning what what uh what does that mean
best you can tell it means that they
basically told Eli Manning that he's
effectively become a placeholder right
now and that if the Giants can find a
better quarterback in a year where there
aren't a whole lot of fries and
quarterbacks where there aren't a whole
lot of quarterbacks in the draft but if
they're Giants can find one that
literally gives them a better chance to
win the day they were gonna make that
move you know I think that's what they
sort of conveyed and they want to get
Eli's thoughts on whether you want to
play and when you wrote down there he
wasn't sure how he felt you want to
process everything and I think
everybody's in wait-and-see mode and the
Giants have the sixth overall pick can
they go get say Dwayne Haskins at that
spot is he gonna be gone before then do
they have to trade up this year do they
have to become the Jets the other New
York team and maybe even trailer to the
Jets spot to go get a quarterback after
bypassing one last year do they think
that they could go get Joe Flacco out of
Baltimore Nick Foles out of Philly they
think those guys are better than Eli
Manning sure I think these are the
quarterback scenario is that Dave
gentlemen and the Giants have to go
through in their own mind and figure out
what is best for this franchise I think
in their perfect world you know Justin
Herbert comes out they go get Justin
over in the draft and they keep you like
mounting around for a year they move
Offerman look we've seen these
quarterbacks rich take the league by
storm there are six quarterback 225 and
younger in the opening round of applause
this weekend and we've seen something of
a passing of the torch because Peyton
Manning is gone Tom Brady
we'll be gone some point the next 20 or
so years Ben Roethlisberger Eli Manning
we don't know how long they're gonna all
about the buoy now I've seen the next
generation of quarterbacks we see right
now
quarterback making a start this weekend
who will become the youngest quarterback
ever to start an NFL postseason game we
see that Prescott Gerry Goffin Rome's
oldest young quarterbacks first second
third year writing it up playing well
leading their teams into the postseason
so the NFL has its next generation a
quarter and the Giants have to go five
one of those guys come out yeah I only
have the next generation of running back
that's for sure and unfortunately their
perfect world will have to be on earth-2
unless just a nerve it comes out and
says you know the opposite of what he
said over the Christmas break by saying
so so the bottom line is you know I
guess the what's the time frame on that
I mean new league year hits and they'll
know what the free-agent period kind of
looks like and in between then what if
Eli comes back so you know what I do
want to play another game for the Giants
a do you want to play one last year I do
want to play my contract out the Giants
what they cut him do they really do that
no that's not gonna happen I can imagine
that they'd ever do anything to bring
the slightest bit of shame to him ever
like they're gonna do this together yeah
gracefully we're not gonna embarrass the
guy that's not gonna happen so III don't
know the timeline yeah it's what these
things will know when we see it hear it
maybe it plays out of combine maybe it
plays out free-agency maybe it plays out
right before the draft maybe plays it
was different and maybe you'll I'm
adding is this starting quarterback on
opening day next year that wasn't
shocked me at all
Adam Schefter here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so I guess so much for josh
mcdaniels burning his opportunity to get
more coaching interviews because he left
the Colts in the lurch last year he is
is he the hottest coaching candidate
right now I hate to find hottest right
because the Bengals reached out the
Packers reached out there will be others
Jets know better right the Jets know
better
the Jets know better did well he's not
gonna go I don't think he's going to
suggest I don't think and and the truth
of the matter is there are coaches out
there right now that you know or
coaching this weekend they may get calls
here later on so
to me no I think Mike Munchak has gotten
a ton of interest a ton of interest I
think he's gonna get a head coaching job
Vic Fangio looks like he's in line to
become a head coach Zac taro the Rams
has gotten a lot of play Adam GaSe Mike
because you know the funny thing is
people said lack of candidates and
that's just not it's just not real and
right Kingsbury wouldn't be shocked if
he landed one of these jobs right Bryan
Flores should get one of these jobs
the Patriots defensive coordinator so
other guys out there and Josh McDaniels
is definitely in demand and I don't
think anything that happened last year
is greatly impacted whether or not
another team would hire him look the one
thing that this league doesn't have a
lot of his young proven successful
productive play colors if you can do
that there's always gonna be a market
for you I don't care how many times you
leave somebody at the altar okay because
there just aren't enough of those guys
so when everybody screamed from the
rooftops last year that Josh meetings
will never get another opportunity ever
again well we waited what 12 months to
see that they're proven wrong mm-hmm and
I know that our guy in Ann Arbor told
you he's not going anywhere he gave you
that nice little exclusive so my
question for you Adam is any NFL teams
gonna still do their best effort to try
and shake that tree with Jim Harbaugh
and then there's John where everybody
seems to think that he's gonna leave
that contract extension open to try and
either gain a little bit more leverage
for whatever's best for him staying in
Baltimore or pull a Jon Gruden which one
do you think is more likely doubt my
mind that John Harbaugh is more likely
at this point in time to be a point of
discussion and speculation that Jim
Harbaugh would be there Jim Harbaugh
when we spoke on the phone I don't know
a few weeks back and whatever that was
was very very adamant that he's not
leaving right now like we didn't talk
about next year the year after we're -
hey you're starting to be linked to
these others I'm not leaving and he says
this comes up everything
a year and every single year I had to
bunk it and he really believes that it's
done in an effort to discredit his
recruiting and it always comes up around
signing day and he was very adamant
about it and even after the rumors about
him and the Jets came I called him up
and ORS texting with him
and he said I don't know how many times
I say like I can't I can't squash this
every single time it comes out but he
squashed it again so I I don't think Jim
Harbaugh is leaving right now yeah I
think you know in the future who knows
what's gonna happen this future rich I
have no idea would I be surprised one
day if Jim Harbaugh coaching FL no but I
I don't believe that's anytime soon
I believe he's got unfinished business
and an Auburn I believe he's tending to
that
as for John Harbaugh that's an unsettled
situation that still could go a lot of
different ways that story has yet to be
told
you know the Ravens basically announced
that night that he'd be back
they really had not been a lot of
contract discussions to that point so
they just sent that message to the rest
of the team the rest of the teams in the
league number one leave our guy alone
and I think in a much more civil way
that if you're not leaving our guy alone
you're just not going to go get this guy
you're gonna pay us for this guy I don't
think that's why they did it but I could
say that's how other teams interpreted
it mm-hmm last two minutes with you here
quick hitters Adam Schefter in 2019 week
one Mike McCarthy will be yeah I I don't
know the answer generation I'd love to
give you a guess reports that McCarthy
is gonna be the coach of Team X so I'm
not gonna guess I you know I would guess
that there's good chance that he doesn't
go true as there is that he does know
that's something he gave me something
right there
that's okay I'll take that levy on bail
will be in week one where do you think
he's going we've got interesting these
are guesses
these are guesses honestly how about
okay all right I give you something now
because you'd like that oh you know
but uh I don't know what the hell I like
anymore to be honest with you yeah you
know I uh honestly what a minute you
think you like something it doesn't work
here's the thing you're asking me to peg
a home for levy on bail yeah in the fall
when there are eight teams 80 teams the
worst teams in the league yeah by and
large with the greatest needs with some
of the most cat money to spend that we
don't know who the head coach is gonna
be so one of those eight teams just
telling all my listeners and viewers
google it and grant will be where's
grunt where's not gonna be you know I
know that he that honestly III posed
that question about a month ago to some
people and their hostility and he wants
to play he wants to keep playing now I
don't know you know the last month of
the season change his mind how he thinks
now you know what his reaction would be
if the Patriots came to restructure his
contract you know the great part is this
we could float these questions we could
discuss some of the answers but there
are just guesses right now it's okay
doesn't want to guess III don't like to
get a then let's move on last question
for you how'd the man I never met go for
you a beautiful book beautiful beautiful
beautiful can't say that word enough
book that you wrote well I appreciate
you know in all honesty I did not I
didn't write the book for it to become a
best-seller I wrote the book as a
tribute to my wife's late husband and to
my wife and the male family and the
number of texts and calls and emails
that I got from people who did read the
book was why we wrote the book there
were some incredible thing is that some
people wrote to me and the fact that it
touched and moved as many people as it
did from that standpoint the book is a
success that every common national it
never did but you know so be it that's
the way it goes and we go on but again
the people who read it by and large have
had very kind and flattering things to
say it's a wonderful beautiful book Adam
thank you it really really really well
and it is and and I can't recommend it
highly enough to people to go out and
buy and get I love you my wife is sort
of handling the future of that book if
you know what I mean like you know wait
whatever you want to do you know because
there are people who have called about
TV series and movies and in all honesty
I told her I'm kind of out like whatever
you want to do and you know my wife
doesn't act with the punctuality of me
you could send her a text and you might
get a response six days later who do you
want playing you in the movie Adam what
do you want well we have to get do you
know what that would be fantastic people
stopped me about that and and in fact I
haven't had I was at the dinner one
night yeah and and all of a sudden all
this dessert arrives the table was back
when I was working for Network and I
said boy I didn't realize that and it's
all networks had this reach and this
distribution back in the day when we
were first starting out there and tried
to build the network into what you built
it today original yourself stop all
those desserts and the maitre d came
over and he shook my hand he said I love
you in clueless way to own it Adam just
take it you just take that dessert and
say thank you because the two of you
never age
you and and Paul Rudd looked the same
the first day I met you guys it's
unbelievable well I think that we had
dinner in Kansas City the three of us
that's nice that was on Thanksgiving
when you when you scooped everybody by
saying Shanahan was gonna start Jay
Cutler after our first ever NFL Network
Thanksgiving game and bench jake plummer
no matter what and that's exactly what
happened and the owner didn't know he
did not I'll never forget when Pat
Bowlen found me in the parking lot
saying where's Adam Schefter oh my god
oh no and that Steve born Stein comes up
to me the head of NFL Network 30 seconds
later where's that of shefte he goes you
gotta find him because Pat Bolin's
wondering where this report about caught
was coming from it
we have fun ones at Thursday night's
Richmond we slept in Oakland right
that's right hey Adam happy New Year to
you into the family rich appreciate me
today nice to talk to you and sorry I
can't be more helpful in some of those
guys take care Adam
you take care that's none other than
Adam Schefter there's nobody like the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience